when joel edgerton called me i thought
well what's the what am i missing what's
the catch she said well here's the thing
you play guys that people kind of like
and the twist in this movie is that
you're not that nice so I want to cast
somebody where they're not gonna see it
coming I was like got it I still somehow
spun that into a compliment James Cooper
was the character I played on Little
House on the Prairie he was a sweet
young boy that lost his parents to a
fiery stagecoach accident he and his
sister Cassandra thankfully were in a
follow a ghen and and and got to see mom
and dad tumble down the side of a cliff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
luckily Charles Ingalls Michael Landon
was was there he took a knee and he said
come live with us and so we joined the
Ingalls family there for a year this was
a character I had to be super sweet with
he had this gorgeous little bowl haircut
that this was just just horrendous I'd
do a lot of crying because you cry a lot
on the Prairie I don't know how I did
that at 11 cuz you know there's a lot of
sort of sophisticated tricks you got to
figure out to cry when you're older nose
hair pulling or burning yourself with a
match or something right before you go
that's what I had to do Todd Howard was
a character there in Teen Wolf too that
presented not a lot of create a
challenge for me except for getting in
and out of the prosthetic makeup which
took a few hours every day back then
they didn't have the ethically safe
chemicals one needs to put these things
on and off and I've literally got
chemical burns on my skin we had to shut
down production for a few days at one
point but you know all for the craft
really you know and the Academy Awards
that we got on the film so you know
worth it mark Loring was the character I
played in Juneau he was a creep
to to some who watch the film and then
to others at watch the film they were
like oh well he's taking a shine to that
young girl cuz he's lonely it's
interesting to to talk to different
people about how they read that movie I
in fact I asked the director at one sort
of crucial scene okay now I have to know
is he trying to you know hook up I think
is what the kids are saying nowadays
with this girl or is he just looking to
connect and have a bond with it and he
said I I don't want it I don't know I'm
not gonna tell you I said well all right
well I'm gonna I'm gonna decide he's all
right then just hide it that was sort of
a an interesting balance and he said do
the scene ten different ways like from
you know totally harmless
all the way up to really lascivious
and in the editing room I will try to
play with all the different takes to
build this ambiguous sort of cocktail
I'm leaving Vanessa what I'm getting a
place in the city and all plans
something I want to do for a long time
oh he cut up that scene with a bunch of
different performance takes and you've
got the stew Michael Bluth was a
character that I played in Arrested
Development this this guy is sort of the
the same person I put in quotes in an
insane family although there are plenty
of times when he was he was pretty
pretty dumb himself let's not play the
bike okay it's the poor carpenter that
blames his shoddy tools for the what is
it like to be a part of a cult series it
certainly didn't feel like it at the
time although we thought we were doing
something that was mildly amusing for us
sickos that were making the show and
fortunately there were enough people
that were equally kind of bent that that
found it there obviously there weren't
enough people otherwise it would still
be on the air but at least on Fox but
there are enough sickos in Netflix to
who want more and more of it so there's
that dodgeball I played a character
named pepper Brooks I believe I was only
on that set for about three or four
hours I play a guy who does color
commentary for a dodgeball tournament
and so they kind of shuffled those
scenes throughout a tournament cuz I was
there for such a short amount of time I
didn't know really how to fit the
comedic tone of the movie I didn't know
what would be too much or too little and
and I remember talking to the the
writer/director rawson thurber about
like should my hair be like up like a
neck tattoo is that too much and it's
like no more crazier bead be a real
dumbass and I said I got that looks like
it's gonna be a too
[Music]
usually you pay double for that kind of
action pot Gary coal was the the other
actor next to me and we were kind of a
two-man team and he's so incredibly
talented at figuring out how to be the
the other balance to some jackass next
to him and he was just beautifully dry
and that was a lot of fun to do that
then we did a bunch of stuff in the the
sound booth months later dadang more
crazy crap Hancock I don't remember the
name of the character I played but it
was I play a PR agent that's trying to
help Will Smith's alcoholic superhero
figure out how to get his his image back
under under control all I really
remember about shooting that movie was
just feeling so lucky to be a part of
some big-ass Hollywood movie with Will
Smith and Pete Berg was directing it it
was just a huge production and I'd never
been a part of anything like that and it
was just really cool to see what this
incredible crew was was able to rig and
the safety units with the stunts and all
the effects and that was awesome I'd
love to do another nother film like that
one day the switch was a film it was
originally called the baster because it
is about a guy that I played named Wally
Mars who boy I'm not sure how old the
people are that are watching this but
what he does is he he takes his well
semen is a clinical term and he switches
it with what his friend Jennifer Aniston
is going to use to make a baby and he
switches out the sperm sample because he
feels like well why not me why didn't
you choose me then they called it the
switch for obvious reasons and she and I
had a really great time doing it and
we've been really close friends ever
since
and that was worth all of it
I play Nick Hendrix in Horrible Bosses
the the character like most characters I
play was not too tough the least dumb of
a super dumb trio and or at least he
thinks the movie was a lot of fun to
shoot everybody associated with a
casting crew we had a really good time a
little too much night work for an old
man not like me I like to be in bed by
4:30 4:45 this went oftentimes to 9:00
or 10:00 at night miss Aniston and I got
to work together again on Horrible
Bosses and Horrible Bosses want to a
pretty fun sex therapy scene try not to
make each other laugh I've just been hit
hard I've been hit hard one after the
other sometimes double fisted you know
you know what I'm talking about so your
sexual addiction it's it's homosexual in
nature my sex addiction my sex addiction
is and then what did you say I think I
think the second one is even better than
the first but well I guess a millions of
people just disagreed identity thief as
a movie about somebody having their
identity stolen middle-aged guy stolen
by a middle-aged woman that was an
incredibly fun job because Melissa
McCarthy was was the middle-aged white
woman and I was very happy that she said
yes it was originally gonna be a man and
then I saw her in bridesmaid and I said
let's switch it to a woman got to work
with this lady and we're still really
close and our daughters are actually
really good friends Seth Gordon directed
that one he directed Horrible Bosses one
and I was lucky that he was nice enough
to say yes to do identity thief another
another good working experience again
not a tough character to play that's
that's a dream you got to try to find
characters that you're not going to
break a sweat playing
so in the gift there was this character
named Simon Callum that I play who when
joel edgerton called me I was very
starstruck to take his his phone call
I'm an enormous fan of his and this
movie the gift is a really great job
that he did as a first-time director
that was a really positive experience we
shot that in a very short number of days
that was a film that Jason Blum produced
and he's got this incredible model where
you you shoot a shoot a movie for not a
lot of money in a short amount of time
and allows you to really keep your
vision as a director exactly the way you
want it because he's not overexposed
financially and the movie did did pretty
well so very very happy to have been
asked to do that Nick Wilde was the name
of the Fox that I played in Zootopia
that's the only well no I did an
animated film a long time ago I forgot
the name of it but anyway check that one
out it's good but Zootopia was film that
did I believe it won Best Picture
animated picture if I'm not mistaken and
that was a really eye-opening experience
to see how they do things over there at
Disney Animation it took us I want to
say three years to do I went in there
and did about 2 hours of work every
three months their process of changing
story around and and and being really
fair to what's working and what's not
and pivoting is a whole different
process since there's no reshoots they
just have to erase it and draw something
else then you go in and and you either
redo something or you do something a
little bit different and when you see it
at the premiere you then finally know
what you've been doing because their
animators are incredibly good at what
they do obviously and it was a real
honor to be a part of one of those films
in Ozark I play marty bird who's this
money launderer who is just dancing as
fast as he can to keep his family alive
and to accomplish this thing he has
promised to do for this this this drug
cartel he keeps making kind of half good
decisions good enough to stay alive but
not good enough to to get out of trouble
his family is obviously very very
important to him and he's justifying a
lot of these ethical II challenged
decisions in order to keep them safe and
to provide Laura Linney plays plays
Wendy bird and together we're kind of
this unit that is trying to figure out a
way out as quickly as possible they're
not interested in two seasons or three
or four like they just want the show to
be over get home and and and make life
boring again and that's something that
the writers keep in mind that there's no
reason the show should continue to go on
unless they write a conflict legitimate
enough to stay in there they get backed
into corners and there's a reason why
they can't go to the cops and end it so
it's it's a really incredibly tasteful
and talented group of people in front of
him behind the camera and I'm really
proud to be a part of that in all of
these roles there's uh there's not a
real big thread except I do enjoy
playing a character that the audience
can relate to and and kind of serve as
that relatable proxy thank you for
pretending to be interested in this and
thank you GQ or